-We´re here
with Chef Danny Bowien,
founder of Mission Chinese Food.
-Hey, man.
-He´s also featured
in the sixth season of the
series "The Mind of a Chef."
The first three episodes are
available on Facebook Watch.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-I´m so stoked to be here.
-And what are we making tonight?
-Okay, so, you know, I cooked
in restaurants for a long time.
I actually grew up
in Oklahoma City,
so I didn´t know I wanted
to be a chef.
I wanted to be a optometrist for
a long time.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But anyway, I went through this
career path
of cooking in restaurants,
thought I wanted to be
a fine-dining chef.
And then I had this dish
at this Sichuan restaurant.
Have you had Sichuan food
before?
-Yes.
-Has anyone here had Sichuan?
Do you like spicy food?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So I was 26. I thought
I wanted to quit cooking,
and I was, like, I was over it.
And I had Sichuan food
for the first time.
-Where did you have that?
-In San Francisco...
-Okay, great.
-at this great restaurant
called Spices II.
-Okay, great.
-So, anyway,
I´m going to make a dish
called Chung Ching
chicken wings.
And it´s, like, a very spicy,
numbing,
tingly chicken wing dish,
and it´s usually hammered
under a big blanket
of chili peppers.
-Very excited about this.
-I´m gonna fry
some chicken wings.
You know, chefs like to be
know-it-alls.
One day there was a debate of
who has the best chicken wings,
how do you make
the perfect chicken wing.
And one of the guys in our
kitchen chimed in
and was like, "Well, my mom used
to work
at the Anchor Bar in Buffalo."
Buffalo, New York,
where the buffalo chicken wing
was created.
So we´re like, "Okay.
How did they do it?"
And they fry their wing twice.
So that´s what we´ve done here.
So we have a wing that´s been
fried and then frozen,
and then now we´re frying it
again.
It´s kind of French fries.
That´s why McDonald´s
has great French fries
is they´re fried, frozen,
and re-fried.
-So you´re McDonald´s food.
-Basically.
[ Laughter ]
I did grow up in Oklahoma.
-Okay, yeah.
-So where did you grow up?
Where did you grow up?
-I grew up in New Hampshire.
Yeah, so the way we make
our chicken wings
is we don´t fry them at all.
-Really?
What do you do?
It´s like rotisserie-style?
No, my mom actually --
the way -- we don´t even --
My mom would just get
frozen chicken wings,
put them on a pan,
and just throw them in the oven.
-Okay, well, that works.
-Nutritionally it doesn´t work.
-Yeah, well, you know, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-Should we have a cocktail, too,
while we´re here?
-Sure. So this is probably best
to drink after we eat the wings.
-Great.
-But let´s put it together.
-Okay, great.
You´re in charge.
-I´m gonna let you do
everything.
Well, we should shake this up
first.
This is called a Phil Collins,
that´s one of our signature
drinks at the restaurant,
it´s basically
coconut milk infused with gin,
lemon grass, and ginger.
And we let it set overnight.
You want to scoop some ice
in there?
-Yeah, sure.
-In these little bowls.
Why do you call it
a Phil Collins?
-Well, I mean,
I like Phil Collins a lot.
And our beverage director
when opening,
I was like --
his name´s Sam Anderson,
I was like, "Let´s make a drink
that´s, like,
just name it after
Phil Collins."
And he was like, "Okay.
Let´s make something
that´s like a Tom Kha soup.
Like a Thai soup."
So you can pour this
into those little cups there.
-You should call it
a Phil Collins
because you get drunk enough
that you see someone
that you think crossed you
in high school.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s a very specific joke
for nobody.
-I was like, "Uh..."
All right, so we´ll pour that
in there.
While that´s happening,
I will take the wings out.
[ Laughter ]
I will help you.
Well, you hold, I´ll pour.
-Okay, great.
Is there any pouring music?
-Could we just get
a light pouring drum roll?
-Phil Collins? Is there a
Phil Collins-pouring music?
-It should be drumming.
[ Drum roll ]
There we go!
-All right, cool.
So we garnish this
with some kaffir lime leaves
a little bit of dried chili.
-Okay, great.
-This is a little bit
of chili oil.
-Gotcha.
Wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
-But I´m going to wait
to drink mine until after.
>> Okay, well, so am I.
-´Cause, you know, you know.
[ Laughter ]
So the good things about cooking
the wings twice
is they get super, super crispy.
So, like, you can look at these,
they´re really super crispy.
And we´re gonna drop them
in here.
And then these are
all the spices.
You know, Sichuan food,
it really prides itself
on having things that are sweet,
salty, spicy, tingly.
And that comes from this --
it´s Sichuan peppercorns.
So Sichuan peppercorn,
fennel seed,
cumin seed.
I forgot to grind up
the black cardamom,
so we´ll just throw those
in there whole.
-Okay, great. [ Laughs ]
-Cayenne chili pepper.
And I have all the stuff
premixed together
for the magic of television.
Here, I´ll let you do this.
You can just shake,
and I´ll just dump this in here.
-This is for those who are
watching on TV and can´t smell,
it´s kind of overwhelming.
-It´s intense.
So you can just dump that
on this plate here.
There we go.
-Okay, great.
And then the beauty of this dish
is --
You can dump all this
on there, too.
-Okay.
-The beauty of this dish
is that it literally is
under a blanket.
-Are you gonna let me eat
the premade ones?
-Yeah, you can eat either.
Either, or.
-Can I try one now?
-Yeah, sure.
-How spicy is it?
-Try one of these.
These are the best.
It´s pretty hot.
It´s very tingly.
-Okay.
-And I think that´s
from the Sichuan peppers.
-Okay.
-You ready?
I can only eat one of these,
by the way,
at the restaurant, so let´s see
how long it takes us
to take a drink of that.
[ Coughs ]
All right.
What are you feeling?
-What´s happening?
-What are you feeling now?
[ Laughter ]
-It´s happening now.
Oh, my God!
Whew!
-Anybody want one of these?
No, yes, yes, pass them back.
Pass them back.
All right. I need a drink.
-Okay.
-Anyways. Cheers.
-Cheers, that was fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Danny Bowien, everybody!